[Música]
para mí es un placer estar aquí con
ustedes esta tarde
como mucha gente saben y otros no lo
saben
yo vengo de una familia larga
estamos hablando exactamente
de 16 hermanos
estamos hablando exactamente de nueve
mujeres y siete hombres y más
exactamente estamos hablando de ocho
hermanos de padre y madre y ocho
hermanos de padre sí porque mi papá tuvo
ocho hijos más durante su feliz unión
matrimonial con mi madre que duró más de
52 años
cuando yo digo que tengo 16 hermanos la
gente siempre me dice que usted sabe los
nombres de todo esto y yo digo claro
señores pero son mucho por son mis
hermanos
además sangre de mi sangre pero entonces
viene la siguiente pregunta que que
develó el nombre de ellos
pero yo creo que hay en ese gancho
siempre tengo aquí en el bolsillo un
papelito
que reza de la siguiente manera no lo
leo porque no me lo sepa lo leo porque
no quiero que alguien se sienta mal si
no lo mencionó
mis hermanos son miguel wilfredo alberto
1 alberto 2 andrés 1 andrés 2 del sila
mari down y alexandre elena tdt oli
morena y denis cariñosamente pochola
pertenecer a una familia
de tantos hermanos te enseña muchas
cosas cosas que te van a ayudar durante
toda tu vida lo primero que te enseña a
ti es
a compartir claro porque tú tienes que
compartir pero señores me estoy
refiriendo a compartir compartir la cama
claro compartir los los zapatos de tu
hermano que más grande que tú tú lo
heredadas compartir los libros del
colegio compartir el baño la ducha la
toalla el jabón la parte diente
compartir absolutamente todo hasta la
respiración hay otra cosa que te enseña
a venir de una familia de tantos
hermanos y es a sumar restar pero sobre
todo te enseña a dividir
claro porque si tú no sabes / puedes
entender en cuanto cabe un solo pollo
entre 8 bocas
pero si contamos a mami a paramos día y
si contamos alta grasita la muchacha que
nos ayudaba
estamos hablando de 11 personas entonces
tú aprendes eso pero también sorprende
que esto es muy importante a negociar
si tú tienes que negociar y volviendo a
la división imagínate en cuánto cabe una
televisión toshiba blanco y negro entre
8 pares de ojos
eso cabe a uno nada más pero qué pasa la
negociación comienza cuando mi hermana
deals y se atrinchera y dice que ella
quiere ver su novela favorita se llamaba
mundo de juguetes
entonces bien barba alberto se se
atrinchera también dice que no yo quiero
ver mi serie favorita que es el chapulín
colorado ya tu sabes la que se llama me
estás en esa casa en esa casa es hermana
una guerra más grande que la guerra del
golfo y la guerra de vietnam juntas pero
altagracita la muchacha que nos ayudaba
salía de la cocina con un cucharón en la
boca en la mano que si un momento vamos
a regresar berenjenas me parece que
levanta la mano lo que quiere la novela
que levante la mano que quieren ver
salir colorado
hoy vamos a ver chapulín mañana a ver la
novela y se iba entonces ahí empezaba
esa negociación
ahora bien
vivir rodeado de tanta gente no
necesariamente hace que todo el tiempo
estés acompañado al contrario todos
nosotros sabemos que a veces todo está
acompañado por estar solo en mi caso
particular yo siempre buscaba las
maneras de aislarme y una de las formas
que encontraba de aislarme era sentarme
en una mecedora que me regalaron el día
de reyes
cerrar los ojos y meterme este dedo en
la boca y ahí me quedaba yo por horas
escuchando en el radio de la vecina de
al lado doña lourdes en paz descanse su
alba un programa que daban en las tardes
titulado 100 canciones y un millón de
recuerdos
ahí me quedaba yo escuchando si en
canciones y un millón de recuerdos la
canción es más hermosa que usted se
podría imaginar viejísima todita
deprimen ti si mato dita pero el
indígena todita cuando yo pienso en
ciertas canciones y un millón de
recuerdos pienso en canciones que llovía
como sombras nada más entre tu vida y mi
vida oigan la vainilla sombras nada más
otro y que existen el amor que me
juraste depresión también otro viejo
hermano vine a verte no es para pedirte
nada y aunque pobre estoy viviendo
reconozco la intención todo era una
especie de presión y también
esta me gustaba mucho esta tarde vi
llover' vi gente correr todo era triste
señores pero yo sin embargo me iba en
medio de esas historias de las historias
de las canciones y navegaba y yo era un
personaje dentro de esa historia y yo me
imaginaba pero por qué fue que ya se fue
esta tarde vi llover' yo me vienes a
señores con ocho y nueve años
otra manera de aislarme
era comiendo boca
para los que no entienden el término
procedo a definir el término conmigo
mismo
el combo keys mo no es más que el arte
de prestar atención a la conversación
del prójimo sin que el prójimo se dé
cuenta
aun estando en la misma circunferencia
hay mucha gente que menosprecia lo
cómodo que este asunto de boca un
momento un momento el como kiss mo es un
arte milenario
que tiene sus reglas primero todo el
convoca que se respete aprende a ser
silencio
para que no se le vaya nada
segundo un como boca profesional y que
se respete nunca opina
aunque te guste el tema mi amor
acuérdate que comiendo boca que tú estás
solo contigo tumba eso
número 3 un come boca que se respete
jamás repitan conmigo jamás jamás
pactará con ninguna de las partes
involucradas en el conflicto
[Aplausos]
cuarto un come boca profesional y que se
respete tiene que estar atento a los
pequeños detalles señores porque si
usted pierde un pequeño detalle ese
detallito pequeño puede ser el que queda
el que catapultó una p cosa o que genere
el próximo chisme
o no
y algo muy importante
quinta regla un como boca profesional en
el ejercicio de sus funciones tienen que
entender que sus oídos su boca todo su
cuerpo no es más que una esponja que lo
absorbe todo y que no suelta nada
realmente a través de él como mismo yo
descubrí señor es mi verdadera vocación
no no es mear
estamos hablando de contar historias a
mí particularmente me encantaba escuchar
como el boca para ver qué fue lo que
pasó quién le dio aquí en que lo que
está pasando el bochinche bochinche pero
después entendí que no que a mí lo que
realmente más me importaba eran los
personajes porque la historia no es la
historia sino el que vive la historia el
que cuenta la historia el que sufre la
historia el que llora la historia
entonces qué pasa con el tiempo
aun estando en el ejercicio del
comunismo
la mano de dios me saco fuera de esta
isla y me llevo
a otros territorios a otras historias y
a otras personas
y ahí en medio de la soledad yo comencé
a hacer algo
que debí haber hecho antes pero inicia y
comencé a documentar esas historias a
documentar esos personajes esos
personajes han estado conmigo
durante toda mi carrera
esos personajes han marcado mi vida y yo
pienso que esos personajes fueron parte
de un sueño que en el escenario poco a
poco
cada vez que subo se van haciendo
realidad
estos personajes tienen fechas y tienen
lugares y hoy por lo menos los cuatro
primeros vinieron conmigo
no no tan allá afuera niños
están aquí adentro
rompeolas
verano de 1992 new york city la calle
christopher street yo disfrutando del
gameplay viendo las carrozas que venían
bajaban los travestis y todo el mundo
y a unos cuantos metros de distancia me
encontré con ella era flaca flaquísima y
estaba vestida de plata y rosa y tenía
unas antenitas como la del chapulín
colorado' su voz era estridente tan
estridente que era más fuerte que todas
las voces del pare y cada vez que pasaba
algo que ya le gustaba ya gritaba
familias no bring ero
familia sobrino pringles
y yo
me quedé mirándola porque me llamó
muchísimo la atención ella su flacura
todo ella se quedó mirándome y me dijo
dices getting fabulosos baby la mitad no
son tan gorda y beris 11 may problema
pero voy a tener con hasta que esto se
acabe en esta bola está primero
y se fue toda la christopher street
hasta cruzar
al puerto al puerto que da el río hudson
se perdió de mi mirada pero no se perdió
de mi corazón yo me quedé pensando
porque ella me dijo 'han con nota hay y
me dice un amigo bruto ella está
infectada era la época de la furia mucha
gente moría de vih de sida y eso fue lo
que ella en este momento de alegría me
confesó
por eso decidí que iba a ser parte de
una de mis historias
llegó a la que falta avisarles del
asunto rompeolas yo soy mi amor dios yo
te voy a de fuego la estrella máxima de
este club está allá afuera sentar en su
maleta esperando un empresario diego que
según ella prometió llevarla en gira por
los países escandinavos
mientras tanto vertida y otras locas la
costra del día lo miran todo desde las
ventanas voy hinchando a ver si ese
hombre finalmente llega qué bonita
familia qué bonita familia
esto
quise decir que poco fabulosa que poco
glamour le dio el tiempo con familia
pero que se puede hacer mi amor si bola
de fuego es como la escuela en
vacaciones no tiene clase
vengan
[Aplausos]
invierno de 1994
venía bajando la estación del tren 19 de
la calle 181 con san nicolás
y ahí conocí a un hombre
y a una botella de ron
camine entre al tren él entró detrás de
mí yo me senté él se sentó frente a mí
y como hacemos los dominicanos que tú me
dice hola y yo te digo y te cuento mi
vida entera
me punto de cómo llegó a puerto rico en
dio la de cómo llegó a nueva york de
como no tenía documentos como hace 15
años que estaba ilegal y sobre todo me
contó también su deseo de volver a la
isla y me dijo que debajo de su cama
tiene una maleta repleta de ropa nueva
esperando estrenarse la cuando volviera
el tren se detuvo en la calle 204 él se
desmontó y yo seguí y espero ese hombre
que no tenía nombre decidí llamarlo papi
chino domínguez
y en la mano que dura que a la calle por
poco no llegó hoy a quito y el papel yo
venta o que respira bajo el agua y donde
quiera cae encendido que acelere mano
que acelere entrando por esa puerta me
callo atrato nito betánces directo el
fundador de esta institución y me monto
contados la durable me dijo papi chivo
el manito del alma
ayúdame la sala está llena ahí arriba
hay una loca que se la dé en poeta y al
que le toca la primera parte
está en el baño cagándose de los nervios
ja ja ja ja le di para atrás le dije
métanse es con halo gastón para que no
se caiga déjenmelo a mí que soy experto
en improvisación en que esta gente me
encargo yo
con la barba damas y caballeros señoras
y señores bienvenidos sean todos ustedes
que te encuentro de solidaridad comunal
gracias por esta oportunidad de verdad
yo creo que me la merezco por mi talento
por mi carisma y porque yo y ahora sí
con y no sé qué y tengo mis que se dijo
que ssg para la la la la la la la la
agarra de esa nota
[Aplausos]
1995 sanz busca restaurante calle 679 y
broadway
yo sentado en la barra comiéndome la
bandera
y a unas cuantas mesas la vi a ella
la chica que me está
sirviendo me dice esa fue una de ellas
fue famosa y como que se quedó en esto
todavía ella cree que yo una diva
alguien intentaba hacerle una entrevista
como con una grabadora de pila y ella
hablaba bajito bajito el hablar bajito
un truco de las divas claro porque
mientras más bajito tu habla la
humanidad se calla y te escucha
solamente había yo milito de voz que
decía sin amor como te va diciendo
me quedé observando la ella me llamó me
brindó una cerveza habló conmigo yo
decidí que ella se llamaría sasha la
reina del patronato
[Música]
buenas noches al gracias gracias por tan
apoteósico recibimiento un tanto apagado
bueno mi amor yo diría que bastante pero
que importa una diva que se respeta
nunca sea joven
permítame presentarme a una necesidad
pero yo insisto apelando me a las ferias
de la educación nocturna
a que todo el mundo se lo sabe pero lo
repita porque la memoria es tesonero
porque las memorias prisioneras
la gente me llama de tantas maneras me
llaman la vida me llaman las calles me
llaman la en creemos natural beautiful
para ti pero tu confianza y la confianza
van de sosa
la veterana
yo trabajaba en el baño de una discoteca
llamada kitkat cloud en nuevayork calle
43 entre la sexta y la quinta
había llegado con mi amigo roy que iba a
ver a su madre que trabajaba en el baño
de al lado atendiendo a las mujeres
tenía gloria cariñosamente mami yo ya
entramos un instante al baño y entró
esta mujer descompuesta nerviosa va
directo al baño y mami yo ya le dice
pasión mi amor que lo que te pasa
y ella dice es que tengo ahora
como alguien se llama pasión
comencé a hacer preguntas y pasión no
hablaba nada pasión estaba tan en
drogada que se miraba en el espejo y
mami yo ya me contaba la historia de
ella paso a paso paso a paso
pasión se fue yo me quedé con ella y la
hice mía pero le puse apellido dije te
vas a llamar pasión contreras
pero fue que no me presenté en todavía y
se los dije a los de la organización que
no me pusieran de última porque la
pasión se desespera pero no me hicieron
caso que no está bien está ya la propia
a la propia que se joda verdad ustedes
están del ustedes están del
de la voz ay bendito señores como
tanto a ustedes
qué van a pensar de milk interés para
haciendo al arte de mi mala educación la
pasión un poquito café pero aún técnica
y original
ahí es que vengo ahora esta mañana le
dije a popeye el marido mío clics en pop
ex
esta noche voy a ir a un encuentro de
solidaridad como una gripe y me
respondió loquito un uso con pie pero
vine ni weiss porque quien le dijo a
papel y que el man de mí esos tiempos
pasados mi amor la pasión es libres
libres libres con los pájaros hay popeye
pompeya compendio de escarmiento
pabellón actual mentor y con el último
botellazo que yo le dije
137 puntos señora desde la frente hasta
la nuca me fracturé el cráneo 9 años de
concubinato tirados a la basura por una
raya de polvo blanco lo dije bien no son
obscena a cualquiera doctora gonzález me
advirtió que lo dije a la cocaína
bendito y que por eso era peor
[Risas]
la historia no es la historia la
historia es que la cuenta
mi trabajo no tendría ningún objetivo si
no me importara los personajes que
protagonizan las historias ojalá que
nosotros dentro de todas las cosas que
hagamos tengamos en nuestro corazón y
bien pendiente al ser humano porque al
fin y al cabo sin ustedes sin nosotros
el universo no sería el universo gracias
termino mi tiempo
[Aplausos]
[Música]